what's going on everyone it's joe to
loan more back with another video today
i want to talk about gardens and how to
water them efficiently in a process that
i love to do i've had it for years now
and i absolutely love it so let's get
started
[Music]
so the process that i'm going to talk
about today is right here in these three
raised beds right here it's called drip
irrigation now i did a video on this
last year
i think it was too much of an in-depth
video it's very simple to do very easy
to do anybody can hook this up
you have plenty of options out there to
get this stuff you can get them on
amazon you can get it at home depot or
lowe's i got my stuff right at home
depot um so if you run out of something
you can go get it bring it back and put
it together so right here is a perfect
example of drip irrigation you can see
right here we have these emitters right
here i'll show you how i've run it to
this to the sprays bed here in a second
but what these emitters are they what
they do is they drip every six inches to
12 inches depending on the style that
you get and what you can find but what's
really great is just a little bit of a
droplet that basically
drops into your garden a little bit at a
time and that way it controls the flow
of what's coming out into your beds the
great thing about drip irrigation is it
can hook right to your faucet to the
side of your house as you can see here i
have a melnor water timer i've had this
for probably three or four seasons now
haven't had a problem with it as you can
see here i have two different settings
right here on my melnor water timer i
have the one here this is for actually
the drip irrigation line you can see
here this is the half inch pipe that
comes with it it goes into a obviously
you want to have a backflow provider on
there and then this one's a two port
they also sell four port if you're
interested in that if you're interested
in above ground irrigation these things
are really great you can set them up to
four different cycles meaning four
different times of the day they can come
on this is a two zone obviously has a
manual off and on so if you wanna if you
see a little bit of a dry spot in your
garden and it doesn't the timer you know
comes on at a certain time and you want
to hit that a little bit extra you can
have a manual on off
i've done a full in-depth video on the
4-port one i show you how to set it up
i'll leave that link below it's a very
popular video because it is a little
confusing when you first set these up
but again i have my drip irrigation
right here my half inch pipe it runs
down and it basically what happens is
that half inch pipe right there runs
right along everything that you want the
half inch pipe that i have runs right
along the bottom
of my
uh mulch bed right here and then it goes
all the way back into my garden and then
from there you can branch off to various
things so let me tell you let me explain
to you what i mean by how branches off
of that so this is the half inch pipe
that you can buy it obviously you real
you really need this this is what
connects to the timer that i showed you
behind me uh there's a couple different
fittings that you can get very easy to
figure out so i'm not going to go in
super in depth i just want to give you
guys the basic idea of how the drip
irrigation works but basically this half
inch line is what i use as my main line
and then from there i branch off to
everything the shrub right here behind
me the rose bush has is branched off of
this to a nice emitter that feeds it
regularly on schedule every day so
that's why these rose bushes right here
behind me they look really great all my
shrubs always look really great
throughout the time of the year because
i'm always branching off of these half
inch pipes right here so what you want
to buy is one of these hole punchers
right here and then all you got to do is
punch puncture a hole right into the
tubing right here
i have a couple right here but there see
there you go and then from there you can
branch off to wherever you want to go
so obviously there's a bunch of
different accessories that you can get
you have some of these right here these
are some different fittings there's a 90
degree in here there's a uh there's a t
in here so if you want to branch off the
two different spots you can and then
from here these are the drip emitters
right here uh actually the company that
makes them is called dig
i think these ones are sold at home
depot
but as you can see here this bag right
here has a 10 pack and it does uh it
does
two gallons per hour so
i really don't go off the the gallons
per hour thing i just kind of judge what
my plants are doing if i think my plants
need a little bit more water then i'm
going to upgrade the timer if i think
they're getting too much maybe i'll down
the timer just things like that i don't
get too carried carried away with the
gallons per hour i've used these
emitters here for years now and they've
worked just fine so what you want to do
is you want to branch off of your half
inch line right here so what you want to
do is use one of these little guys right
here basically what this does is goes
into one of the holes right here
just like so
and then from there with another
accessory that you need to buy is these
micro tubes now again these micro tubes
they're a lot smaller i don't exactly
know what diameter is but you can see
it's a lot smaller so basically what you
do they come in a roll i forget exactly
probably 25 50 feet something like that
you buy this then all you got to do is
snip it to how long you want same thing
with the tubing you can snip it they
have end caps on here as well i juice
use regular uh clippers that you use for
pecs
this works really great to snap these
off either or
you can use anything you want um but the
pack but the pex clippers work really
great for this again it has an end cap
it cut you have to buy that separately
it has an end cap so the water ain't you
know obviously squirting out the other
end but from going back to your emitter
right here this is what i was talking
about each of my shrubs or each of my
garden strips that i have i branch off
so again i have my adapter on here i
take my micro tubing
now
sometimes this micro tubing doesn't go
on easily so what i like to do is i like
to use a torch something like this
and if you have something even bigger
you can use one of these guys and all
you got to do is heat up the tubing a
little bit and then
from there you can put on whatever you
want so if i'm going to branch off to
say a shrub i have my micro tube branch
off of the half inch line then on the
other end i'm going to take my drip
emitter right here i'm going to throw
that guy on
and there you go i have one of these
again i'm going to show you in a second
all my flower beds so oh my plants are
getting water just like this drip right
off the half inch line don't have to
worry about don't have to worry about
getting a sprinkler out you don't have
to worry about throwing your hose out
there ordering anything by hand you just
have the water timer on and you're good
to go
so again i have this system all along
this flower bed right here all the way
down each plant is getting a drip
emitter just like this right off the
half inch line so just imagine this on
the ground right here
that that half inch tubing right there
is running all along down the front side
of my house and then it's branching off
to this shrub right here it's branching
off to this shrub right here and then
again all the way down
so what i'm going to do now is i'm going
to flip it on and show you guys what the
drip irrigation looks like in the garden
we're gonna put it on for
15 minutes just so you guys can see what
it looks like
and just like that it's flowing through
so let's go show you so we're back out
back now and as i said this half inch
line it runs literally right along the
edge of the fence all the way down the
fence line and into the back of the
three beds back there and then from
there again we just branch off you can
either use one of these drip emitters
like i have on the end of here or you
could use the drip emitters where it
drips like every six inches or 12 inches
depending on what kind of style you can
find
so right here is a perfect example of
the drip emitter right here this is a
blueberry bush right from hamilton new
jersey and as you can see i have my
branch my line goes way down this way
again that half inch line just goes
underneath all the way down and we're
just branching off and as you can see we
have the drip emitter right here and
it's just feeding this bush right here
and then again we have one all along
here to feed all the other blueberry
bushes some are underground some are
above ground it doesn't really matter
it's going to get fed so here's a
perfect example of the drip emitter
right here the one that's every six
inches as you can see it's literally
just dripping just a little bit at a
time
and we have this all through our three
raised beds i have an actual half inch
here in the middle as well because the
half inch obviously more water is going
to come out of that than these little
drip emitters right here but these drip
emitters right here are a lifesaver it
really does make gardening so much
easier you have your timer set up it's
so much easier to do you don't got to
get out there with the hose anymore you
just put it up on that timer and you're
good to go i'm going to show you those
three raised beds right here and then
we'll finish up the video
and again here you go we have the drip
emitters right here this one i believe
is it spaced out to 12 inches i'm not
100 sure again
you might have to go online and buy
these ones sometimes you don't always
get these ones in store the ones that
are the six inch or the 12 inch emitters
i believe i got mine on either amazon or
on brain bird's website i believe i got
on rain bird's website before i'm not
100 sure um if i can find it i'll leave
it linked below for you guys to go check
it out an affiliate free link for you
guys um and
again
this is a lifesaver and there you guys
have it a quick video on drip irrigation
and why i love it it's really awesome
it's really easy to do if you have any
questions on today's video leave it down
in the comment section below i'll help
you out go check out my video from last
year as well if you're still interested
in more learning more about your drip
irrigation again if you're going to get
in the garden if you're going to have
raised beds like we have right here
these three big ones and we have ones
over there or you want to keep your
shrubs and your plants and your
different rose bushes or whatever you
have irrigated drip irrigation is the
way to go you hook it up it's worry free
goes on the timer comes on goes off
you're good to go if you found today's
content helpful or if you enjoyed
today's content make sure you smash that
like button it really does help out with
the channel if you're interested in any
of my other content check me out on
instagram check me out on tik tok and
until next time guys i'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
you